single by 30 yes but not us no no no
shall we me yes how excited are you guys
for this project I'm extremely excited
about it I think the fans gonna love it
I think it's gonna be very relatable how
did this idea come to be you know our
Channel all three Productions is known
for making like relatable shorts about
relationships and people and experiences
so we thought there are a lot of funny
moments and actually real moments in
this idea of two people making a promise
to get married by 30 yeah I think a lot
of kids when they are younger they have
this perception of what love is and that
30 is really far away
and so you know I we've heard a lot of
our friends have this pact and we're
like what would happen actually if we
actually got there and two people
actually was worth thinking hey we
should actually do this you're gonna see
Peter and Johanna who are played by
Harry Shum Jr and kina grannis along
with the two friends kind of figure out
what did it what it means to fulfill
this pact or go through with it and of
course it doesn't go a lot of plan
always drama now how did you get to be a
part of this project how did it come to
you for many many years we met through
YouTube and they kind of introduced me
at acting back in the day and throughout
the years we'd work together and when
they asked me to be a part of this it
was like such an exciting opportunity
that I was just lay down and they're so
patient with me because it was my
biggest fear in life was acting really
and they like forced me to do it years
ago and now I love it so I have been
really good um well I do the YouTube
thing I've been doing it for about seven
years and I've known of Wong foo and the
fact that they wanted to use me on a
project I was like cool and they're like
yeah you're gonna kind of be like this
you know like guy that goes gets every
girl you know at the bar type of dude
and I was like yeah I could do that the
diversity on this show is so great
because it actually reflects the world
was that important for you guys totally
I think exactly what you said I think
it's representative of what people see
so it's very like it's not forced it's
it's very natural you look at the show
and it's like yeah that's those are my
friends that's what I see when I walk
around
you know everyday you know for us it's
important to kind of show that
especially for Asia Americas that we are
multi-dimensional you know like I feel
like generally on TV or the media you
see kind of one side of us and it's nice
that we can represent another side but
at the same time it's it's it's human
it's what we all are it I think that's
the the ultimate goals for people to
watch this and feel like that it could
be them and it really could because
we've all been through the 20s we've all
been through that journey of finding
what love is you know so Johanna she
she's best friends with Harry not Harry
Peter in high school and they they're
the ones that make this pact to get
married if they're still single when
they're 30 and then Joanna kind of goes
off and has this adventuresome life and
then things don't go as planned chances
back home nearly 30 like oh shoot what
am i doing but she reconnects with Peter
and then they kind of trying to figure
out what happened to her
yeah and Mark is like the old college
roommate of Peter and you know he hears
this this whole pack he's got going on
in joy after like he sees her after all
these years and he's just like what
let's go ask her out yeah so his
character is very just like outgoing and
he's just like oh you know what I'm
gonna help you be like this wingman and
in the process of everything you know he
actually ends up falling for a close
it's it's a roommate and so you see kind
of mark you know go from like this
really like tough you know confident get
to kind of a little bit of a softie and
why was YouTube read the right place for
this show well YouTube's been where our
channels grown and all our fans are
there so we figured like that's the
place to show this series now do you
guys have any personal connection to
this single by 30 situation where did
you make a pact like this in high school
with anyone absolutely you know it oh
wow
really thanks for watching ET on youtube
make sure to you know like comment and
subscribe